المترجم: Sarah Al Khalid
المدقّق: Mohammed dz
مرحباً
عندما كنت في الثامنة من عمري
كنت أعاني من مرض جلدي
ويتركز بشكل أساسي في يدي
المشكلة الأساسية التي كنت أواجهها في
هذا الأمر
أن زملائي في المدرسة لم يتقبلوني
كانوا يرفضون مَسْك يدي أو اللعب معي
كنت متأقلمة مع الموضوع نسبياً،
لأنني كنت أعرف أنه أمر مؤقت
وكانت صديقتي والتي هي بنت خالي هي الشخص
الذي دعمني في هذا الأمر
كناً معاً دائماً ونقوم بكل شيء معاً
فكانت من أكثر الناس الذين دعموني
لتجاوز هذا الأمر.
وفي يوم من الأيام أصيبت بمرض، واضطرت
للغياب عن المدرسة
فكان ذلك التحدي الأكبر بالنسبة لي
عندما ذهبنا إلى ساحة المدرسة لنصطف،
كان الصف ثنائياً، ولم يقبل أحدهم
بالوقوف إلى جانبي
بعدها أتت المعلمة وعاقبتني، وأمرتني
بالرجوع إلى الخلف
وقفت في آخر الصف وكنت فعلاً متضايقةً جداً
لأنها حتى لم تتح إلى الفرصة لتبرير ما
حصل وتبيين ماهيّة الموضوع
أتذكر حينها أنني فكرت أن عريف الصف
يقف دائماً في المقدمة
واقفاً لوحده ولا يحتاج لإمساك يد أحدهم
فالحل لتجاوزي هذا الأمر هو أن
أكون عريفة الصف.
وعندما أتذكر هذه الحادثة، أستغرب من
طريقة تفكيري حينها.
كنت متأكدة بأن هدفي بكوني العريفة
لم يكن لأكون متفوقة،
أو متميزة عن صديقاتي
ولكن الشيء الأساسي الذي كنت أفكر به أن
أجد الحل الأمثل لهذه المشكلة.
أنا اليوم أقف أمامكم وعمري 22 سنة
المشكلة التي واجهتها في سن الثامنة قد تكون
من أسهل المشاكل التي واجهتها
أحياناً نمر بمواقف في حياتنا، تجعلنا نخرج
من حالة الراحة التي نعيش فيها
وتجعلنا نبحث بين الحلول المتاحة، لنجد
الحل الأفضل لتجاوز العقبات.
وخلال سنوات الأزمة الماضية كثير من الناس،
وأنا منهم،اضطررنا لتغيير أسلوب حياتنا
انتقلنا إلى مكان جديد، بعيداً عن المكان
الذي عشنا فيه طفولتنا
خلال هذه السنوات اضطررت لتغيير
المكان الذي أعيش فيه سبع مرات
وفي كل مرة كنا نعاني بالإضافة إلى الجهد
والضغط النفسي
والصعوبات المادية التي كانت تمر بها عائلتي
من ضغط اجتماعي هائل علي
حاولت أن أتجاوز هذه الصعوبات ، وأن أكون
في كل مرة جزءً من حلّها
لأتمكن من الانتقال إلى المرحلة القادمة،
ولا أبقى واقفة في نفس المكان
وبسبب هذه الصعوبات ،
جئت لأشارككم خلاصة هذه التجارب
والطريقة التي اجتزتهم بها.
لأريكم أهمية أن نحاول حل مشاكلنا
بأنفسنا ونعتمد على أنفسنا
أنا هنا اليوم لأشارككم خمس تجارب
تعلمت منها الكثير خلال الفترة الماضية
التجربة التي فعلاً غيرت حياتي ،
والدرس الذي تعلمته منها
هو أن لا تضع حدوداً لنفسك
إذا أردت النجاح لا تضع حدوداً لنفسك
لا تجعل حدوداً لقدراتك و إمكانياتك
لا تسمح للأخرين أن يخبروك بما يمكنك
فعله أو ما لا يمكنك فعله
لأنك أحياناً قد تتفاجأ بالأشياء التي
يمكنك عملها بنفسك
عندما كنت في السنة الأولى بالجامعة ،
على الرغم من الصعوبات التي واجهتها للتأقلم
مع التخصص الذي لا أرغب به أصلاً
كان علي أن أعمل
على الأقل لكي أؤمن تكاليف دراستي وأساعد
أهلي مادياً
كان صعباً علي كثيراً أن أتخذ قراراً
بأن أعمل
وكنت أقنع نفسي بأن شخصاً عمره 18
هو شخص غير ناضج كفاية
ليتخذ قراراً بترك الدراسة ، أو يفضِّل
العمل على الدراسة
و ماكان يزيد الأمر صعوبةً هو كلام أصدقائي
وأقرب الناس إلي
كانوا يقولون: " لن تستطيعي التوفيق
بين عملك ودراستك ، وستضيعين أجمل
سنين حياتك ، وأن الحياة في الفترة الجامعية
لا تعوَّض " والعديد من الجمل الأخرى
ثم سألني شخص: "هل تودين تغيير حياتك ؟"
قلت له : " طبعاً "
قال لي: " غيِّري الأشخاص الذين حولك"
عندها لم ألق بالاً لهذه الجملة التي قالها
ولكن بعد أن نفذت الأمر الذي أخبرني
إياه اكتشفت الفرق
حاولت قدر المستطاع تضييق علاقاتي
مع الناس الذين حولي
ولفترة زمنية محدودة
أُلغيَ جزء كبير من حياتي الاجتماعية
وظللت طوال هذه الفترة أعمل وحدي
ولكن إيماني بأنني أستطيع عمل تغيير
وتجاوز هذه المصاعب
كان يستحق الكثير من الصبر
وبعد أن قررت أنني فعلاً يجب أن أعمل
اكتشفت بأن الصعوبة لا تكمن في اتخاذ
القرار بحد ذاته
بل في إيجاد فرصة العمل المناسبة في ظل
الوضع الراهن الذي نعيشه
كنت كلما تقدمت للعمل في مكان ما
يُقال لي أني عديمة الخبرة
وعلقت بمفهوم أن العمل لا يكون إلا بخبرة
وأن الخبرة لا تأتي إلا من العمل
حاولت مراراً التفكير في حل لهذا الموضوع ،
لأكوّن تجربتي الخاصّة
لأتمكن من خلق الخبرة الخاصّة بي
فكان الحل المناسب أن ألجأ للعمل التطوعي
الصعوبات التي واجهتها لأتمكن من إيجاد
العمل التطوعي المناسب لي
لم تكن أقل من الصعوبات التي واجهتها مسبقاً
لإيجاد فرصة عمل
وسمعت مرةً عن معرض الفرص والمبادرات
اعتبرت هذا المكان كنقطة بداية بالنسبة لي
هيأت نفسي ، وطبعت عدة نسخ من
سيرتي الذاتية
وذهبت مع أصدقائي لهذا المعرض
كنت قد مررت مسبقاً بجميع الأماكن
الموجودة هناك
شركات ومبادرات وجمعيات وأطلب
الانتساب لها
وبعد فترة زمنية ، إحدى الجهات اتصلت
بإحدى صديقاتي ولم تتصل بي
عندها كنت حزينة فعلاً
ولم أعرف ما هو الشيء الذي يجعلهم يتصلون
بصديقاتي ولا يتصلون بي
ومالشيء المميز الذي يفرقني عنهم
ولكن لم أتوقف عندها أبداً
اتصلت بهم وقلت لهم : " أنتم لم تتصلوا بي
ولكنني فعلاً أريد أن أكون معكم ،
هل من الممكن أن آتي ؟ "
عندها بدأت سلسلة من الأعمال التطوعية مع
هذا الفريق وعدة فرق أخرى
وتعلمت بها تجارب كبيرة جداً
هذه التجربة علمتني الدرس الأهم وهو أنه لا
يجب أن تتوقف عند الخطوة الأخيرة
تحقيقك لهدف هو عبارة عن مجموعة من الخطوات
التي تتعب فيها وتعمل بجد وتسهر من أجلها
ومن الممكن أن تفشل في إحدى هذه الخطوات
عندها تحزن ويصيبك الاكتئاب ، وأحياناً من
الممكن أن تستسلم
ولكن عليك أن تعرف أن هذه الخطوة قد
تكون الخطوة ما قبل الأخيرة
وأن جهداً صغيراً تبذله من الممكن أن يوصلك
للمرحلة الأخيرة
أتخيل أنني لو لم أتصل به وأخبرهم بأنني أود
أن أكون معهم
هل سأكون واقفة هنا أمامكم أحدثكم عن
هذه التجربة ؟
فكر بالفرص التي من الممكن أن تخسرها
إذا لم تتقدم خطوة للأمام
وفكر بعدد الأشخاص الذين ينتظرون منك
قيامك بهذه الخطوة
ينتظرون كلمةً أو فكرةً أو حتى مشروعاً
حتى يتغير جزء كبير من حياتهم
عندما عملت على مشروع لمساعدة الأطفال
المُهَجَّرين
وترميم الفجوة التعليمية التي يمرون بها
كنا نعاني من أن هؤلاء الأطفال لا يشعرون
بأهمية التعليم
لا يشعرون بالرغبة في التعلم
اجتمعنا نحن المشرفين والمتطوعين لإيجاد
حل لهذا الموضوع
وقلت عندئذٍ : " حتى يتمكن الإنسان من إحداث
تغيير بحياته ،
يجب أن يشعر أولاً بالحاجة لهذا التغيير،
و هؤلاء الأطفال يجب أن يشعرو أنه يجب
عليهم أن يتعلمو
يجب أن يشعرو بالحاجة إلى هذا التعليم "
عندها أقمنا فعالية جمعنا بها هؤلاء الأطفال
وأخبرناهم قصصاً لنجاح أشخاص
مروا بهذه الصعوبات التي يمرون بها ، وكيف
تمكنوا من تجاوزها
النتائج التي توصلنا لها بنهاية ذلك اليوم
لم تكن قليلة أبداً
وكانت أكثر بكثير مما توقعنا
تشجيع الأهالي لهؤلاء الطلاب كان كبيراً
جداً
والآن ، جزء كبير من هؤلاء الأطفال انضموا
للمدارس مع ذات الفئة العمرية لمن معهم
وهذا المشروع علمني شيئَا مهمًا فعلًا
وجعلتني نتائجه أشعر بشيء أساسي لدي
وهو أن كل إنسان من بيننا لديه مسؤولية
اجتماعية تجاه مجتمعه
من الممكن أن يكون هذا المجتمع قد أعطانا
شيئًا صغيرًا أو كبيرًا جدًا
ولكن علينا أن نشعر بأن علينا رد الجميل
على الأقل
في حياتك سينصحك أشخاص
يقدمون مجموعةً من النصائح والكلمات
أو حتى يقومون بمساعدتك بفعل ما
ولكن عليك أن تعلم أن عليك رد الجميل
، عن طريق مساعدة أشخاص آخرين
لا تجعلو الأمر يقف عندكم
وهو ماجعلني أقف أمامكم
أشارككم هذه الخبرات
أشارككم الدروس التي تعلمتها
والدروس المستفادة من أشخاص ساعدوني
ربما أهم تلك الدروس التي علي أن أخبركم بها
أن الجامعة ليست سنوات الدراسة فقط
لا تقل عندما أتخرج غدا سأفعل كذا وكذا
لا أريد أن تكون دراستي و عملي أقل من
المستوى المطلوب
لا
حاول استغلال سنوات الجامعة بالاستثمار فيها
بشكل جيد جدا
لتبني شيئا أكبر تلجأ إليه عندما تتخرج
إضافة إلى عملي التطوعي و وظيفتي خلال
الدراسة
اللذان أخذا جزء كبير من وقتي
كنت دائماَ أسمع جملةً من أصدقائي
سنرى نهاية ماتفعلينه الآن
وها أنا أقف أمامكم اليوم
تخرجت هذا العام بالمعدل الذي تمنيته
عضو بأكثر من منظمة عالمية و محلية
عملت على العديد من المشاريع وكونت خبرتي
الخاصة
بينما هم يحاولون المضي قدماً
ويخطون بأقدامهم في أول الطريق ليبنون
مستقبلهم
في كل إنسان شيء مميز
أنا، و أنت و كل شخص بيننا لديه شيء مميز
حاول اكتشاف هذا الشيء
اسأل نفسك و من حولك لتعرفه
اعتبره ابنك، أنشئه و كبره
و اعتبره الصفة الأساسية المميزة،
التي تستطيع أن تبني عليها شيء أكبر بكثير
مما تتخيله
بالتأكيد ستواجهون الصعوبات
لكن الفكرة تكمن في كيف ستحلها
كيف تعرف ماذا تريد
كيف تعرف ماهي غايتك و تسعىى إليها
وكيف تعرف تنظم وقتك
و الجملة التي نسمعها دائما
"ليس هناك وقت"
جميع الناس لديهم أربعة و عشرون ساعة
لكن أتفق معهم في أن ليس جميعهم يعرفون
كيف يستثمرونها
يكفي أن تقلل من الساعات التي تقضيها على
مواقع التواصل الإجتماعي يومياً
أو أن تعتبرها منصات غير مناسبة لمشاركة
حياتك الاجتماعية و أحداثك اليومية فيها
بل هي مكان للتسويق لنفسي و خبرتي ومهاراتي
لأُري العالم أن لدي شيء مميز، لأرسم الفرص
لنفسي
في آخر دورة تدريبية ذهبت إليها كانت قبل
يومين في بيروت
عندما اجتمعنا مع الأشخاص الذين
قبلوا طلباتنا قالوا لنا:
"وصلنا عدد كبير من الطلبات"
"وكنا في الفترة الماضية نعمل كجواسيس على
ملفات الناس"
"لنعرف أكثر عن خبراتهم ومهاراتهم وما إذا
كانو يستحقون أن يكونون هنا أم لا"
لا تعتبر أن هذا الأمر غير مهم
ملفك يعطي إنطباعا عنك
حاول استخدامه لتُري العالم أنك موجود
لتُري العالم أنه لديك شيء مميز
لتقل لهم أنني هنا
و في النهاية أود أن أقول لكم
أن الصعوبات في الحياة حتما موجودة بكثرة
و متنوعة
و تختلف من شخص لآخر
و أحيانا نحاول حلها بطرق مختلفة
نتعلم و نكوِّن تجربتنا الخاصة بنا
ودائماً الطريق الذي يحتوي على صعوبات
يحمل في نهايته شيئا جميلاًَ.
و شيئا يرضينا
ومن الطبيعي جدا أن تتواجد في حياتنا صعوبات
لكن الغير طبيعي ألا نكون نحن حلاً لها
شكراً
(تصفيق)